Mr Speaker I noticed there's no Home
Secretary this morning unless the member
for Bassett Law has been appointed Home
Secretary in the last few hours which to
be honest nothing would surprise us at
the moment because this is total chaos
we've got the third Home Secretary in
seven weeks the cabinet was only
appointed six weeks ago the home
secretary's been sacked the chancellor
sacked the chief whip sacked and then
unsacked and the unedifying scenes of
conservative MPS last night fighting
like rats in a sack this is a disgrace
the former home secretary has circulated
a letter and that seems to contradict
what the minister just said because she
said it was a draft or a written
ministerial statement that was due to be
published imminently and had already
been briefed to MPS is that not true can
he explain the answer to that and could
he tell us also what time the Home
Secretary informed the cabinet Secretary
of the breach and whether a check's been
made of whether she sent other documents
through personal emails putting security
at is was there a 90-minute route about
policy between the Prime Minister and
the former Home Secretary and given the
huge disagreements we have seen over the
last few weeks between the Home
Secretary and the Prime Minister on
drugs policy on Rwanda on the India
trade deal on seasonal agriculture on
small boats and a bit of tofu thrown in
over the letters for good measure is
there anything that the policy is
actually agreed on in the cabinet on
home Affairs what we know is that the
former home secretary has just been
running her ongoing leadership campaign
whilst the current home secretary is too
busy to come to the house because he's
doing his spreadsheets on the numbers
for whoever he is backing to come next
but who is taking decisions on our
national security not the Prime Minister
not the past or current home secretaries
borders security policing are too
important for this kind of instability
just as people's livelihoods are too
important for the economic instability
that this conservative party has created
it is not fair on people and to quote
the former Home Secretary this is indeed
a total Coalition of chaos why should
the country have to put up with this for
a single extra day
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker I'm sure my right
honorable friend will be aware that
breaches of the ministerial code are a
matter for the cabinet office not the
home office and that is why I am here
answering the question today and not to
the Home Secretary
but the Prime Minister took advice
around the cabinet secretary as you saw
from her letter and she is clear that it
is important the ministerial code is
upheld and cabinet responsibility is
respected the Prime Minister expects
ministers to hold the highest standards
and you've seen that act consistently in
this regard
but these were breaches of the code the
Prime Minister expects her ministers to
upsold the ministerial coat as the
public would also rightly expect and she
took the requisite advice from the
cabinet secretary before taking this
decision
and I'm mindful it's not usual policy to
comment in detail on matters like this
Mr Speaker but if it would be helpful
with background and appreciating much of
this is already in the public domain the
documents in question contain draft
governments policy which remains subject
to Cabinet committee agreement
having this on a personal email account
and then also sharing outside of
government constituted clear breaches of
the code sections 2.14 and 2.3 if
helpful to look at
the prime minister is clear that the
security of government business is
Paramount as is cabinet responsibility
and ministers must be held to the
highest standards